not only the conversation we just had
people hey reg I'm John I'm Hector
Navarre dr. Nefario G's news is you need
writer man that that stuff you don't
have the goggles in your head no but
crazy
no no I'm Supergirl Thank You Roger
cougar from the josh mokuba show on
youtube and of course Collider videos
collaborative geez be talking other
Collider segments don't watch our
interview that John Humphrey and I did
in John even Kouga show yes where we
talk politics races religions awful of
that various their daily solves the
North Korea yeah you guys know that
actor named Thomas Cruz right I know
impersonal Thomas j.crew Thomas J Cruz
Thomas Jonathan Cruz is from Florida
later Sean these has his new movie
coming out but I'm definitely skeptical
about called The Mummy know is the
featurette called stunts I wonder if
it's about Tom Cruise doing a bunch of
stunts
I predict that many people will talk
about how great tom is intimidated and
probably say it's like touch upon me how
much of a daredevil
and how him onset inspires them
he really is fighting Tom goes 100% he
legit thinks that he is a mummy in these
scenes and it's really attested it to
the writers and the challenge that tom
is able to pull this off because he is
100% our greatest actor in cinema right
now because this is the thing like this
is the thing that sells every Tom Cruise
movie right now is what the crazy life
risk he's taking this time in this one
he actually turns himself into a mummy
he wraps himself he puts himself in a
coffin for upwards of a hundred years
and he comes out it's a gravy but we
cracked time friends tom is that mummify
told you to record
I mean honestly if we're going to say if
we invent a time machine who's the one
person we send back in time
some strong gurus there's only one
person to represent our society
perfectly and it's Tom Cruise put the
Scientology aside he's gorgeous looking
he can run really well in his hammer
oven and he does his own stunts
he makes women sign contracts of
marriage I mean a guy genius he's in
perfect man let's watch mom minutes huh
it's gold right now I'm gonna have great
action and real thrills
in order to be wild and violent and
erratic and spontaneous you have Tom
Cruise in between these so huge for us
change the game because the game is
infectious you get a copies of every
time that or maybe banged up his passion
been realized made determinations like
the ways were cool
do some epic you mind you up with this
childhood enthusiasm or your life I want
to make them rue Lee County
he's ready good at pushing to keep it
real why'd you tell our something the
beautiful oh yeah that brings of those
we do good driver and it's a false to
either and really good think okay that's
just for someone in that whoa
Wow building the collapses in town Omaha
others we're gonna do a bailout and is
going to be that adrenaline rush and
you're going to love it and then you're
gonna go start let's go again I was go
again he loved it oh the irritating to
the treadle wheel plane always pushes
the boundaries I'm sixty-four navabi's I
wanted to fall TV I know that I need
look pretty but that's really that's how
fun windows I think of everybody he
works and would and he brings every
ounce of energy he has to we could write
these things I felt very brave relative
insider bravery and that's been
incredible gift to give someone
never seen somebody dusted in my life
certainly had a replacement crowd about
the effort is spent to make something
with quality that means a lot to me
[Music]
yeah who could find at the end computer
girl it's really me
oh yeah
and you know what trips me out is after
gonna hear about Tom Cruise doing some
so I always think of like the huge ones
yeah you're off the building the
airplane secrets and rogue nations yes
but even seem like those smaller stuff
like him rolling down a dirt Hill we're
gonna Mike's why me event into a padding
roll let somebody roll down the hill I
was like 14 anything yeah yeah it was
like 72 this one she's yeah I mean I
guess you got to give the Duke credit
listen I gotta tell you guys before this
we wrote this future it's incredible
there that spot on a building but do you
guys watch TV blinders on that now it's
an incredible series watching it's only
18 total episodes at this point so it's
not it's every season 6 episodes abuse
is that the one with my man killing
Murphy yeah yeah awesome yeah so hit the
love of his life is the girl that played
the lead in the mummy jaws her name is
Grace in she died issues and Ashley
stops back and in paid blinders but
Tommy it's not like Tony but it is a
[ __ ] she is she's awesome in that show
but we could watch stump all day and
they look incredible still did nothing
for me for the movie but we going to do
is really good thing here's the thing
that's this ended and I feel two very
different ways about this at the same
time but when this ended I thought to
myself it really seems like The Mummy
just sold me Tom Cruise yeah what I saw
the trailers I kept saying like I don't
feel like I'm gonna go watch a mummy
movie because I don't know what Tom
Cruise
mission upon arrow and mommy yeah my mom
it's not only a beautiful that's what
that's what it feels like though and
then watching this name is Nick man and
maybe it made me a little more okay with
going in to see a Tom Cruise film that
seeing a mummy was whatever one thing it
did for me I mean I'm a Jake Johnson is
saying as much control as tom has as a
producer when he was saying like this
movie working with Tom because we wanna
make the movie that he sees I was
thinking like well you're not making the
movie Tom's you ever seen the movie
think Tom hit me because he doesn't
director or writer behind us I would
love the benefit
kind of directory like I haven't done
anything though yeah Tom basically this
is really just Tom's we've done yeah
Tom seems like he does have a lot of us
saying how his movies turn I'm already
done and I mean that's that's what's
weird to me about this is like on the
one hand they're really putting this on
Tom Cruise left and if this doesn't do
well let's do the people going to look
at Twitter look at this presume yeah
yeah it's Tom's vision yeah but on the
other hand I do think that Tom Cruise
involvement does bring something to this
giant movie at least when he shows up
for a giant movie they throw down on the
physical stuff like this he's great
intensity to like that beta the Furious
just came out and we saw that and even
though that wasn't by all means a
tremendous film you know like fun they
put a lot of effort into really smashing
cars and stuff a lot of the time and
doing it
full-scale and this is like watching
these action sequences I think Tom
Cruise movies are better than Fast &
Furious movies like like that same level
of like yeah at least if they're going
to rip up London a lot of that is going
to be really spectacular with real
stunts and stuff yeah well even like the
one inside the studio to the green
scream of the car slipping and then he
falls out of the car at the land that's
a hard one to and I'm going to make sure
you get right when you're starting off
sideways and those zero-g planes if
they're really really expensive to do
but my buddy is a producer on The
Bachelor and they did it on The Bachelor
this season and so they took a couple of
producers up in it real quickly to show
them like do you think that the
contestants would want to do this and he
got down he was like this was a lot and
they shot you saw the scene in that 0x
plane it's pretty incredible yeah pretty
cool yeah well hey I mean if the
bachelor can do it Tom Curran we should
do that's right with Tom Cruise and Adam
could go through the group it oh my god
I believe every woman who falls in love
with him
and you accept this rose oh yeah I have
to get audited okay what else there this
is I even though the overall movie I'm
still skeptical about we all is still
sing cuz I don't remember like when the
mummy was announced with Brendan Fraser
that everyone was like it's Brendan
Fraser's movie the monkey sure he or the
original prevision are you insulting the
Hollywood legend that is Brent I know
you've amazing you're just a jungle in
Europe you're insulting school time in
and one of my favorite growing up movies
blaster on the pad is a great like great
I tell you what when Brendan Fraser
short career of a perfection he was in
some incredible no totally dunno man
school time which on I don't that this
is yeah I mean do these people be able
to dude and the money franchise
basically launched Scorpion King which
then launched the rock you know if we
come across truth in the rock inviting
people think about that the origin story
of the rock WWE yet but mostly it's for
scorpion and then flood forward as being
a museum he imagined Tom Cruise the next
Fast and Furious movie potent I can
actually believe that put them and I
think they would go back to not being
real cars and you be involved in the
actual yes of the cars yeah there yeah I
think stalkers would be a perfect
building so it tends and charming at the
same time we're now we're just talking
about expendable spotlight yeah but with
best in the period it has to be the kind
of villain note who like has a really
clear and justifiable purpose who at the
end of the film wind up working with
their turn like because it's Tom Cruise
how many of these is really good
evidently some show up to the water this
alright okay well hey I'll fill you're
watching this movie despite whatever
people say about I'm like yeah I'm going
to opening weekend too I'm too curious
to see how this turns to Fast and
Furious that's actually the biggest
thing
this movie has going for it for me right
now is I am very curious about this I'm
not hopeful yet we've shown furious
enough to wait till it comes I'm serious
and what I would love more than anything
is it somehow charm you know like yeah I
really don't want it to be good cuz it's
the money like they're bringing back the
classic so yeah this should be good I
think what they need is a feature it on
who the mummy is a little bit more yeah
yeah I do feel patella who's from
Kingsley yeah oh she's really cool and
she's in the college blonde yeah Star
Trek beyond right going on and I think
that right now only one really cares
about a Tom Cruise I want to care a
little bit more about who the mummy it
anyway let's move on with our lives okay
her name isn't I subscribed I'll reject
click that notification bell click
recently launched patreon have an
interview with a cougar coming up John
Humphrey reasons with Jerry on Twitter
and Instagram AKA MVP at the movie
trivia Schmo down click them joshua
Kouga from the show down as well clicky
it's what are you
everyone's here at Jessica good nut
woman the ymax right Josh McKoon
of the real rejected episode of the
judgment Commission correct correct you
can go on and start representing the
real rejects when you play this role
announcer now we caught up our
reputation out on Joshua cougar show on
Josh Berger show of the Jester cougar
show go check it out on YouTube where
John and I got an interview on the
jungkook show and he's on Collider
videos Collider TV talk come cottage
cheese guy oh my god is everything
Collider to those one of the main faces
just love him at door of utha oh thanks
babe the main mug so good you're Marlon
Brando makes me become nostril